oh it's a perfect tag team that's the
guy identified as the guy who Ates
Israel to begin with here with reaction
former senior adviser to president Trump
Steven Miller podcast host tutor Dixon
tutor your reaction uh I'm calling it
the Hamas caucus because even with all
the evidence there you have you know
groups of of democratic Congress women
the squad out there propagandizing on
behalf of Hamas can you explain that to
me well with AOC I think it's pretty
simple she's a useful idiot in this
situation Shea Al leave is dangerous but
I'm thankful for the First Amendment
because we know exactly where she stands
anti-semite is too nice of a word for
Rashida to leave this is a woman who has
made it clear she was celebrating on
October 7th she wants Jews to be killed
she it celebrates the murder of Jews and
my question is where is the rest of the
Michigan delegation because this is a
woman who is in a powerful position
she's a leader in the Michigan Democrat
Party and yet I haven't heard Gary
Peters condemn her I haven't heard
Debbie stabel condemn her Ive heard
Haley Stevens condemn her and when Haley
Stevens was asked she says well those
people can make their own decision but
I've told you where I stand wait a
minute you have someone in your own
party who is standing with terrorists
who is standing with people who go in
and murder people in their homes in an
ally Allied country you are okay with
that you are not going to condemn your
colleague I am calling on the Michigan
Democrats to come out and say they do
not accept this they do not agree with
this they are glad they know where
Rashida Talib stands and they want to
make sure that people vote against this
kind of rhetoric what is your reaction
to this step Miller in spite of all the
evidence you know they're still out
there spewing their lies demanding
investigations when there's no need for
one uh I mean h how do you describe
these people in Congress and what should
be
done well first of all they are
regurgitating the propaganda of The
Butchers and barbarians who murdered
raped brutalized and kidnapped innocent
Israelis and Americans that is a moral
stain on the Democrat conference in the
United States Congress and Rashida Talib
should be expelled from Congress for
continuing to provide sympathy and
support and ideological Comfort to the
Hamas barbarians that have Savaged
innocent Americans American blood is on
the hands of Hamas I think this comes
down to the fact that you have a strong
movement within the Democratic party
that is both deeply anti-semitic and
deeply anti-American and anti-west and
so they're going to side with the
terrorists and they're going to side
with the entities that house and support
and shelter the terrorists against what
are perceived as American interests
American lives and American Allies and
it is absolutely revolting it is
repellent this is taking place Sean in
the Democrat party today well I guess
that is the modern democratic party
there are no moderate voices anymore and
then you have the ultra Extreme as we do
here um I thought we weren't supposed to
blame victims unbelievable anyway tutor
Dixon Steven Miller appreciate you both
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else